hey guys what's up this is Andrew which
instances.com so in today's video guys
as usual I'm gonna go through AMC and
gme price action we had today some very
very interesting press action the global
market dropped heavily Jimmy was up AMC
almost flat so let's analyze all of that
let's get into it oh right yes I'm going
to start with AMC I'm gonna as usual
start by reminding you reminding
reminding you guys what I was saying in
yesterday's video so uh I was bullish I
was telling you that we have reached the
21 the 61.8 FIB ratio of the first move
up which I believe is only the first
wave I think we are on the second wave
and I was saying yesterday that we have
reached 21 which was a strong support
and also the 61.8 FIB ratio I was also
telling you guys that we are arriving on
the at the neutral area of the RSI 15.
so let's analyze what happened today
first we dropped by a little bit less
than four percent when the global market
was thinking guys by 2.5 percent uh even
almost three percent during the day I'm
talking here about the NASDAQ triple Q
so it's not that bad day and I have uh
some good information as usual to show
you so first
um
the RSI has only yesterday the RSI was
at 51.5 I think something like that and
right now the RSI on AMC daily time
frame guys is at
49.9 okay
49.91 I told you in yesterday's video
that between 45 and 55 usually we see
some reaction for the Bulls I'm going to
show you what happened today it's very
very interesting but the first thing is
that the RSI has only reached right now
at the end of the day uh the 50 neutral
area so uh the second thing I wanted to
show you guys is that we are below the
21 level which is let's be honest not
very good but I'm going to show you how
we went there and the good thing that I
see is that we arrive just on the 20-day
moving uh 20-day 20-day moving average
at 19.8 which is usually acting as
support so we are in an area of support
between 19 and 21 even if we're below 21
I'm still bullish I told you yesterday
that I'm expecting the third wave to
start either today which didn't happen
or tomorrow so I think it's gonna happen
tomorrow of course it can happen later I
don't know this is only my view uh once
again my analysis is based on FIB ratios
on moving averages on support
resistances on the energy that the
market has when I look at the RSI on the
volume on the volatility and today when
I look at the volume I have some good
some interesting information I can see
we had a stronger volume for the first
time
and you're going to tell me yeah but it
happened on the red day so it's not good
and you are right to tell me that this
is what I would tell you but the
interesting thing guys for those who
have followed the price action during
the day I did because I bought this
morning
um so I didn't I lose just I lost just a
little bit of money today in my trades
um
because I bought at the beginning of the
day and I want to show you what happened
at the beginning of the day so whenever
you see this increase in volume it's
interesting to know who where this
bigger volume is coming from is it
coming from a red candle or green candle
so let's zoom in I'm going to hourly
timeframe and Bam I can see that the
bigger volume of the day occurred just
after the happen on a red candle so once
again I'm gonna say ah so it's a victory
of beds and when I look at this candle I
can see that it's the candle that
actually went to 29 21.9 guys and we had
a very actually
um bullish reaction during the Scandal
and let me show you guys that even
better let's go to 15 minute time frame
and here finally it's clear we'll see
what happened
and once again for those who are here
during the day what happened guys is
that the global market was tanking
and AMC started to Rally we had this
negative beta that we always see during
uh some very strong moves up that AMC is
doing uh at least this is what happened
the five five the five pass times AMC
moved strongly higher
um last year in in the last year and
here as you can see those two green bars
which are definitely the biggest volume
we see we have seen for the past okay
the past week I would say the five the
the past five days
and those two green bars happened once
again on a strong bullish reaction of
bulls which for the first time happened
and where did it happen it happened
around 21. so I would say that Bulls
tried hard today I was buying here I
bought during just before those candles
I was not buying during the move up
um but about just before maybe some of
you both here and maybe some of you were
bullish I was bullish I was looking at
the rest of the market look at that guys
I have prepared that this is triple Q so
let's check the timestamp the timestamp
is here bam six apples uh at 16 okay so
I have uh probably French hour whatever
I take the same time stamp six April 16
and you can see that the NASDAQ triple Q
during this candles was dropping
strongly so we had the global market
going down during this 15 minutes and
AMC and gme I'm going to show you that
as well going higher so this is very
positive this is the first time we see
that in the past week this is some
negative beta that took place I don't
know if it was some shots covering
probably not because once again I think
shots are going to cover higher
um but it's a good sign to see this
negative correlation at player
so uh Destiny was the good news that we
had today I Was Here full of hope uh I
was I was thinking that we're gonna
finally uh start this uh third wave we
didn't uh baz got the best of it it's
like that this is trading guys
um we never know what's gonna happen but
at least I'm happy to see that we had
this strong bullish reaction when when
the global market was thinking and once
again if the global market was going
strongly higher today maybe we would
have a massive move up of AMC maybe it's
not easy to say but what we can say is
that even with the global market moving
strongly lower AMC uh did quite a good
performance to me and was training
positively at the beginning of the day
then we got rejected here guys
around this trend line uh some of the
hourly time frame I think this is uh to
uh this was yeah this is the 20 hour
moving average simple moving average so
as you can see it's acting as resistance
so right now we are consolidating here
so guys let's be very honest I don't
know what's going to happen uh but I'm
happy to see this consolidation we
always have those small consideration
then either we go lower or higher so uh
the past three times we we got them we
we went lower
um I hope that this time we're gonna go
higher once again I think that on the
daily time frame we see that we are in a
support area we see that the RSI is at
50. I have many reasons to believe that
bulls start to really attack uh you know
the price action by buying massively
like we saw this morning despite the
global market tanking so maybe once
again bears are gonna get the best of it
tomorrow I don't know but I think that
Bulls are gonna make one more attempt I
bought today tomorrow I don't I don't
think I'm gonna buy I'm probably not
gonna buy but I'm gonna buy next Monday
I have a program so I'm just going to
follow my program when I share in this
code by the way and and yeah and I can
sum up what I said in my yesterday's
video I think that whenever we're gonna
start to move higher and we see this
volume increase I'm happy to see this
volume increase even if it's on a red
day it happened the big volume happened
between green candles this is some
volume that is created by bull so even
if at the end of the day Bulls lost
money which is not good I'm still happy
to see this increase in volume and I had
a question uh this morning in my Discord
which was what
signal can can make you very sure very
confident that the third wave is
stunning and my answer was
um we need to close above 32 33 all
right so as long as we are not we don't
see this close above 32 33 maybe the
third wave is not going to start right
now maybe we're gonna keep consolidating
even maybe dropping I don't know but I
really believe the third wave is going
to come very very soon so let's see I'm
gonna anyways analyze everything with
you guys to me this prosection is still
bullish as can be seen on the other side
that is still above 50 okay a little bit
below 50. so let's see what's going to
happen tomorrow I'm of course bullish we
are just above the 20-day moving average
we had some strong reactions on the
volume at the beginning of the day we
had some negative with that play and I
have also some good news look at triple
Q so triple Q 15 minutes I showed you
that guys so once again on Triple q and
also I had a comment yesterday uh on my
video that was saying I I hope you're
not gonna lose too much money and guys
uh I'm long AMC of course but I'm short
the rest of the market so today I made
money despite the move down on AMC
because I shot QQQ here I can show you
that guys this is in my Discord
so today those summer trades so I I
bought some AMC here uh April 14th 27th
call May 20th 40 call and I reduced my
short position on Triple Q as you can
see here I bought at
351.5 and at 351 I bought 100 shares of
triple q that I was shot so I made money
today and as you can see the reason why
I bought here guys is because I sold
here because this was a resistance and I
bought here yes because this is a
support simple so I don't know what's
going to happen but I think my view was
that yesterday and it's still the same I
think this is what's gonna happen so
let's see maybe tomorrow we're gonna
break out below that if it happens I
don't know what's going to happen on AMC
maybe we're gonna have a negative bit at
play but let's be honest it's better to
have a bull market it's easier for EMC
to go higher and here I'm happy to see
that at least we have completed this
move yesterday I was telling you guys
that I don't know what's going to happen
to the global market but that I'm
bearish and today I'm not bearish
anymore I'm now neutral I took profit on
the special position personally
I'm not building a long position on
Triple true yet but I'm having some long
positions on AMC on gme on different
stocks I'm going to keep buying AMC and
other stocks guys I have a portfolio
made of many stocks I have a diversified
investment so of course I'm I'm having a
bigger position on AMC and Jimmy
especially right now that I increased
recently because I believe that
something big can happen but I'm I can
lose money on that because I made money
guys on the rest of the stocks on the
rest of the market during the past three
months I made quite good money so this
is the reason why I can take this risk
and even if AMC drops
um I'm gonna be fine I'm gonna be fine
I'm gonna hold my position so I just
want to tell you that guys because I
don't want to
um encourage some of you to go too big
on AMC just buy what you can lose this
is what I'm personally doing I only
invest what I can lose whenever I buy
some call options on AMC and know that
maybe I'm going to lose all of this
money and if it happens I'm fine with
that okay so just something that is
important for you guys to know let me
now so let me finish quickly my view on
Triple true so uh we had an increase in
volume as you can see here uh the FED
minutes were to me not hawkish not
dovish I mean they gave a lot of
information about the um the the the the
the pace with which they're gonna
um buy back their
um their assets so no big information uh
to me from here and right now I think
that the market needs to take a
direction I think it's going to be an
upside if it's the case it's going to be
good for AMC now let me show you guys
what happened on Jimmy because gme guys
was up today up two percent all right so
uh whatever can be said
uh this is a negative beta that is that
lasts until the end of the day we are
here still above this uh trend line that
is acting very well as support the
problem with this kind of trend line is
that that going lower so every day that
is passing the support is drifting lower
all right fair enough but to me this is
a very strong price action just like I
was saying yesterday we can analyze here
the same way what happened on the 15
minute time frame and you guys can see
that so here we didn't have this very
big increase in volume
um but we still had this negative beta
at play and at some point during the day
Jimmy was trading
um at almost 160. uh let's go on The
Daily time frame let's check the RSI of
gme how is it yeah it's very size still
very high at 58 higher than yesterday
um so this is still very bullish once
again I had also some questions telling
me if you think that Jamie's mobile
foreign
and I answered but I can answer again
the reason behind is that those two
stocks for the past year are moving
together I basically what I did and I
explained that during my life but maybe
some of you were not here I just took uh
I checked in the pasture where the
biggest volume was trading trading on
AMC and gme and it was at 87 uh on Jimmy
at that time AMC was training at 14.5 we
also had a lot of volume trading trading
at 130 on gme
so I can show you that guys where it was
but I mean the 130 is coming from here
okay we had here a lot of volume that
was trading recently at that time AMC
was trading uh it was here guys at 20 uh
sorry
psych sorry about that guys
okay at that time AMC was training at 21
then 250 MC was training at 45 you can
go and check it's gonna take too much
time to show you all of that in this
video guys but basically I checked where
we had the most volume trading and uh
what I think is whenever you have a big
volume trading this is a level that is
considered as a fair level all right
guys so I checked then the ratio between
the levels between AMC and Jimmy each
time we had a lot of volume training and
I saw that this ratio was always between
5.7 and 6.8 so then I considered that
this is the fair ratio roughly six and
uh using that I can know what is the
fair price of AMC if if Jamie is trading
at 156 and the answer is this divided by
6 is 26 guys okay so right now AMC is
trading at 20.4 and it should trade at
26 so AMC is trading at a discount and
this is is the reason why and I'm not
the only one that is doing that I'm sure
that a lot of Traders are doing that and
this is the reason why maybe some of you
are wondering why those two are always
moving together it's because their
correlation is very positive for the
past year and whenever this happens
whenever you have two assets that are
moving always together with massive
massive volume a lot of trailers are
playing the spread okay and I'm
monitoring the spread so I'm and I'm
once again I'm sure I'm not the only one
to do that and I can tell you guys that
uh
that's some big money players are gonna
buy a lot of AMC soon okay or sell Jimmy
but once again the price action is very
bullish on Jimmy so I believe they're
gonna prefer to buy AMC which makes more
sense so this is the reason why and
right now the spread is at 24 yesterday
it was 20 today is 24 it's the biggest
spread I've seen
uh in the past two weeks uh between
those two so once again maybe this
spread is going to go to 30 maybe 40 but
I can tell you that at some point it's
gonna come back to zero or something
close to zero and it's gonna stay there
uh maybe one day it's gonna diverge but
right now those two stocks are
representing the meme movement and I
don't see any reason why what we had in
the past year would no longer be here so
this is the reason why I think that AMC
is running at the discount compared to
gme now let's go back on gme price
action uh what else can we say we can
quickly check the fibs so we had a
perfect rebound on the 38.2 percent FIB
ratio at 153 today we have a positive
RSI we don't have the volume getting
bigger so the price action is still calm
on uh gme so once again maybe we're
gonna have Jimmy just staying here and
AMC doing a strong move up or maybe
we're gonna have those two moving
together I don't know uh but to me AMC
is trading at a discount and Jimmy is
extremely bullish so this is the reason
why I'm that Buddhist on AMC but once
again I don't know what's going to
happen and we I'm gonna keep updating
updating you guys about all of that so
that's it for today I hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and Bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when I upload anything
new and stay close to show see you guys